alexis provoquer c'est le bonhomme à la
bonne place aujourd'hui c'est le seul
hors de toute façon il faudra bien que
je pense au fond que toutes ces
critiques de plein de gens qui ne
supportent pas laurent wauquiez
notamment pour des raisons historiques
ou de personnalités qui estime qu'il est
pas fiable sa non pas une immense
importance si sa maman finlande
aujourd'hui se passe à la question n'est
pas là la question c'est est-ce que
wauquiez va réussir à reconstruire et à
recréer un lien avec les électeurs et
cette question à l'ailier notes et l
ailier manceau multi principalement
qu'est ce qui va se passer du côté de
mâcon est ce que macron va réussir et
auquel cas y aura plus d espace pour
laurent wauquiez pour longtemps est ce
que voyant un reflux est ce que à ce
moment là wauquiez sera capable d'être
le réceptacle de ce refus à presque 10
pierpoljak moi j'écoute eu quand même
connu l'époque on disait chauffage sous
chirac l'époque on disait sarkozy
sectaire sarkozy c'est l'homme seul
c'est pas ça qui compte
ou on est en situation et on essaie
faire venir un électorat et les
dirigeants ils suivent toujours le
problème c'est pas les dirigeants c'est
les électeurs